hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Astro near now I have
been excited to play this game for a
long long time I heard about it first
right before I went to Cincinnati for
vacation but I'd wanted to play it back
here in LA because I wanted to
experience it fully I didn't oh my god
oh no oh no oh yes oh yes I'm sorry I'm
geeking out of it and there's a little
bit of lag probably because it's loading
an entire planet oh god I love it I know
next to nothing about this game other
than you are an astronaut engineer and I
I love space and also I used to almost
be an engineer myself so that can only
mean that I could absolutely freakin
love this what am i doing what does my
spaceship have a dick why okay you know
what I'm just gonna leave that the way
it is tab oh oh oh I'm tethered oh my
god I have no idea what's going whoa
okay point there's something over there
alrighty then
terrain tool shaped what is that oh I
don't know what I'm doing it okay I've
got power that way [ __ ] goddamn it
okay so I've got power compound needed
solar I don't know what any of this
means but I love it lithium needed
battery oh okay so I need to gather
materials to be able to do stuff I think
and I don't have enough materials to be
able to do that oxygens at 50% that
doesn't that doesn't seem good
whoa I don't know why I did that
yay woo okay milder whoo Oh kind of woo
okay I'm out of Woo's oh no that's
that's probably not how do i oh I'm not
tethered anymore Oh God okay all right
then
well I need to get some [ __ ]
how did I pull out my oh that's right
collect resin okay oh no oh yes oh I'm
accidentally terraforming everything
here but I'm just gathering enough
resources to be able to do what I need
to do oh that's so cool oh that's so
cool
oh man I can extend that wait oops maybe
I should put away this tool here stand
whoa no way oh no way
whoa cool that's awesome okay so I need
more I need more resin I don't know
where to get resin I don't think any of
this is resident this was yeah sorry
make it a big old puddle here but
they're but they're dead okay I got
enough for one unit of resin I am out of
power
help I'll buy I need more power to be
able to do that powers over there I did
the resin okay so I need I need to be
able to make oh this is like that's
awesome oh that's awesome
it is like acid it's it's astronaut
engineering oh that's so cool give me
some of that I need more power I don't
know how this is gonna be power exactly
unless I'm just sucking lava out of the
planet itself but I'm not gonna complain
oh I can get all this organic material
man what kind of crazy-ass tool is this
okay wait I've got plenty of organic
stuff I don't need any more of that so
what I need to do is I need to extend
the range of this to be able to go
farther but I've got a lot of organic
stuff needed I've got no copper no
compound whew it's getting dark
oh it's getting dark oh it's getting
dark but the sun's coming up oh no
that's a bat that's an asteroid or a
moon or a planet or something oh my oh
my god how deep does this go oh how deep
can I make this if I was persistent
enough would I be able to burrow through
the entirety of the planet and if so
fucking-a me
sing oh my god I can't my life be this
why can't my life be in space why can't
I be in space okay I just be in space I
just really want to be in space guys
okay so I gotta find what is over there
I don't know what that is over there but
I want it I want it in my backpack
oh is that some sort of living Creed
what is that what are you I'm gonna suck
you up I don't know if I should have
done that but I did it Oh more power I
don't know how or why but I got that
okay I got plenty of power
I got no space for absolutely anything
is it a crash oh that's awesome I don't
have enough power to get over there but
I'm gonna get over there as soon as soon
as I figure out what the hell I need to
do okay but either way I need God okay
so backpack a DD compound aluminum man
wind valve solar battery so I don't have
any of these compounds I need to make
some sort of a storage thing oh that's
right ah yeah okay so that's good um I
could extend it out farther oh no I
don't have any resin damn it okay so
what I got to do is I gotta go find
resin or I'm gonna explore a bit I'm
gonna take a little bit of oxygen with
me and I'm gonna I'm gonna go as far as
I can and try to explore the landscape
to see what's there's something over
there it's some sort of looks like rock
like material maybe it's a copper maybe
cuz if I have copper yes no it's
compound okay I do need this though so
that's good
I got compound whatever the hell that
means I've just got a random assortment
of compounds an amalgamation if you will
Oh bitte boo-boo Oh Oh No well maybe I
could push this back hey you're coming
with me
if I ride out of oxygen before I get you
back I'm gonna be very pissed I'm just
gonna play soccer with a ball of
compound real quick oh that's a I'll
come back for you will soon I'll come
back for you okay bye who do I know I'm
about to die I'm aware I'm
this fact I know these things I'm aware
okay so what I need to do is I need to I
have to compounds smelter I don't think
I need a printer maybe research I could
either make the research or the smelter
I'm gonna do the research first yay yay
okay so now I need to put in power how
do I do that how do I do that tonight
can I just enjoy oh no I need to make
like some sort of solar panel right also
I need to figure out what to do with all
the plant material in my backpack
because that's just taking up space and
I don't eat it here so what do I do
about that all right I don't know I
don't know it's not telling me exactly
what I need but I need it oh man I need
to know so much more about this I've got
too much [ __ ] in my back can I get rid
of that oh oh oh that's handy I don't
know how that works but that's handy
that okay so I can just drop that there
and then come back for later okay I'm
sorry I'm freaking out so much about
this and I feel like I've totally
ignored you guys the old tire time that
I've did been freaking out about this
this experience here but I freaking love
space
I love the possibility that we could
conquer the Stars even though that
probably won't happen in my lifetime but
I just I love the idea of it like the
idea god damn it get that forget just
get in my bag damn it how do I get you
in my pack let's put it there we go
that's yep BAM okay I just love the idea
that we can do so much more in this
universe than what we've done on this
planet because the universe is so
incredibly vast as no man's sky has
shown us it's infinitely boring
what happens if I just dig myself into a
hole probably nothing has [ __ ] gotta dig
my way out of this one Oh running out of
oxygen that's not good
well I'm about to find out what I do and
I die well that's not good
okay well much like subnautica I forget
to breathe a lot and I'm about to run
out of oxygen I'm sorry
hey just you know informative I'm
currently Suffolk
okay there we go okay so I need to find
a way to make some sort of a God I need
to find a way to make some sort of a
thing
I need more resin that's for sure but I
doubt there's any more resin down here
yeah it doesn't seem to be anything I'm
now detecting any resin but I'm using up
a lot of power that's for sure okay so I
need to go out and I need to explore so
I'm gonna go over here there's a lot of
organic materials but I'm wondering
about this crashed looks like a space
shuttle or something like that I mean
there was obviously people here before
us but maybe there were just other
people like myself other failed
engineers that came out here and decided
to be terrible at what they do okay I
don't need more compound but I do need
to find out what this is all about why
is this here Oh resources thank you I'll
take that yes please power I can't see
[ __ ]
can I see [ __ ] hopper yes please copper
yes please okay that helps thank you I
didn't even need to mine for it what is
that what are you
ooh can I have you oh cool
but it's nothing is it okay I can't do
that okay gotta get out of here oh I'm
gonna suffocate oh great
ah [ __ ] am I gonna make it this time the
answer is a solid maybe I've been asked
earlier I should be smarter in this but
I'm so stupid I forget to breathe this
is why I could never actually be an
astronaut cuz I would totally forget
about the the the fact that I need
oxygen to survive okay I did it I did it
okay so what I need to do is I need to
make I need to make some sort of power
thing and I remember there was copper
compound ooh no compound can make a
solar panel so then if I take that solar
panel right there then I can apply power
to this or maybe okay maybe if I make
another one I can put this on there to
get power because either way this is
good because now I have solar panels
that can give me power Moberly so maybe
I don't need to do that anymore but if I
could somehow transfer one of these bad
boys
right there yes like that and then I can
do research right Yes No maybe so whoa
look at that research over there I don't
know what's happening but it's oh it's
getting power oh that's so cool I don't
know what he's gonna research but
hopefully something good maybe I don't
know I'm just excited to be here I'm
just excited to be alive in this grand
time okay but I still haven't discovered
what organic compounds are necessary for
but I'm gonna explore out again who did
it get power I don't think it's all the
way up yet okay that's getting power
I'll be back in a second and then I'll
come back once I find something else of
value but I know that I don't need power
now what the hell is that oh it's a
compass nice
oh is that oh that's that's resin I need
that primitive
yep-yep-yep yep-yep-yep yep-yep-yep [ __ ]
I'm out of power
oh that recovers quickly I need to make
another one of these eventually but I
don't have enough compound for it got to
get back before i suffocate again but
I've got a lot of resin which means that
I'm gonna be able to extend one of those
debt oh there was another one over there
that's why I got that I should be able
to make another one of these dude a DS
because if I put that there then I can
make a printer because I have two copper
[Music]
bingo-bango I don't know what this does
but it's dang cool
oh that one solar panel feeds power to
all the other things well that's awesome
so I know I could make more than that
but that's so cool that it all shares
the same power source oh I got one of my
backpack too but I guess when the Sun
Goes Down I'm not gonna get any power of
about that what that's so cool oh I love
that I love that I still don't know how
to use this but I love that how do I use
you I don't know but I have you that's
all the batter's maybe now I can use
plant material where'd that plant
material go can I put you
what okay well I did that
oh it's storage containers okay I think
maybe I don't know man I don't know I
don't know what to do with this I don't
know what to do with that I don't know
what to do with anything here all I know
is that I love it I love it I love it
all it's all amazing and I like it a lot
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go get
more have enough resonant yes so what I
can do is I can make I can extend this
out so I can just keep extending
preferrably and I'm just gonna get more
resin there's tons of it here I mean I
don't have a lot of power right now but
hopefully I'll be able to get enough for
a fuse
no give me power oh nice Oh
so that's like a regenerating source of
power there don't ask me how that
happens I mean if that happened to real
life I guess it would be sort of nice oh
wait it's called uh and okay that should
be everything that I need for a few more
oh no I need just a little more
come on show me the money show me the
resin show me that sweet resin baby come
on give it to me uh nope didn't get
enough for a third one but that's okay
cuz I only need a few more I'm just
gonna keep piling out this way nice okay
so that's good so that's a nice loooong
chamber to be able to get power to go
and each of these individually can make
another so cool god I need to stop
saying the things what is that
why is it blue it's like the power
things but it's Blair oh I don't know
what that is oh I don't know what that
is oh oh so no oh I can make a trip far
out I can make a long trip I love that
so much oh my god a cave hell yes I'm
going in that oh my god a cave I don't
want to go in this Oh
that what is it compound I don't know
it's oxygen in here
Oh God are there monsters in this Oh No
Oh what does that it's moving it's
moving unknown unknown I don't like that
oh I don't like that at all Oh No we get
some more oxygen here let's destroy the
entirety of the cave system then find a
way to tunnel out of here oh boy I hope
I have enough power for this I bet I
don't Oh God that's not good oh boy oh
boy okay you know what before I go down
into the cave of death I would actually
explore the surface first and not die a
horrible painful death which I know you
guys would love to see and don't worry
I'm sure that's gonna come in the future
but for right now I'd like to survive
just a little bit longer to be able to
explore this wondrous environment and I
finally found a way to get oxygen so I'm
able to go forward and I'm assuming that
eventually I'll be able to move ah what
the [ __ ] is that why is it pulsating oh
why do all aliens need to pulsate so
much whew I don't want to touch it oh
[ __ ] you're so good yeah it's like worms
but really solid stick like worms or
what have we got here anything worth
doing can I bring some of these back
events Oh apparently I can Oh what am i
holding how am i holding this why is it
going into the distance well okay you
know what I'm just gonna use my
incredible telekinesis ability to bring
this back whatever the hell it is I did
not see good thing anyway because I'm
almost out of oxygen anyway at least the
portable variety this is so cool
this is ludicrously cool I am having the
time of my fricking life with this game
this is delightful and amazing and I
love every part of it oh it's so cool
okay I don't know what I got oh for
research Oh perfect oh I put this on my
research thing yes yes please yes please
god damn it god damn it
there we go okay and then there then I'm
gonna research that okay go for it
Oh fuel condenser great I don't know how
that worked and I'm not sure what it did
i I don't assume that research is a
random chance but I like your style so
anyway this is all the time I have for
the first episode of Astra near I want
to play this game so much more
I am so intrigued by this because number
one I love anything to do with space but
also this is just fascinating think this
is just really cool this is like
ludicrously cool and moderately scary
because not only is space cool it can
kill you
pretty much everything in space exists
to kill you we are not meant to live in
space it is supposed to be horrible and
death like and nothing should be there
and yet I can't help and maybe I will
but most likely I won't be able to but
there's a lot of fun this far so thank
you everybody so much for watching it
let me know what you thought of it down
the comments below and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]